tonight on CBS it's the Big Bang
Theory's big crossover episode with
young Sheldon and right after on young
Sheldon McKenna Grace is back as
Sheldon's nemesis / crush but how much
do in Armitage and McKenna know about
each other mr. Jim Parsons plays an
adult children on the Big Bang Theory
if you could pick any actress to play an
adult Paige who would you pick and why I
think Reese Witherspoon because she's a
lot like Paige and legally blond so
you're breaking up with me because I'm
too blonde she's awesome and kind like
you so have you worked it I have she's
the best
oh wow she's awesome yes McKenna didn't
realize a young Ian also has a role on
big little lies I didn't do anything who
is one star you haven't met yet and you
would be really stretched up to me Meryl
Streep I've I've been obsessed with her
I know you've met her
yes Ian became pals with Meryl while
shooting season two of vll meanwhile
tonight on CBS he and McKenna get into a
tiff during a slumber party you know I
read that adults who had a stunted
childhood often become social misfits
and weirdos you didn't read that you're
making it up what is your favorite part
about coming to set and guest starring
on young children everyone is really fun
and relaxed so that's really nice
oh no we've got to keep up the relaxed
part if we're not relaxed you won't like
it so we all know that Sheldon has some
unusual habits what do you think your
most unusual habit is i jam-packed my
bed full of stuffed animals so that I
barely have any room me too I'm on like
I have like literally this much space
just sleep with me too lazy way too
adult they even have stuffed animals a
wife and usually a child on there too
[Music]